welcome to the opening em curry yeah I
lost against him not too long ago don't
remember that game and v6 this is not
seen too often generally it is believed
that white gets a very nice position
against those setups quite often black
young blacks best bet is some kind of um
yeah and a second-rate French a little
bit like here I mean it's not terribly
bad for black but it's not considered to
be a as good as a as a main line opening
as in this French the bishop on b7
that's not making much sense
just playing a normal conservative let's
say development moves of trying to do
anything fancy let's prevent any taking
and night before stuff okay so it's
going for this one
gaining some space here and setting up a
king side attack I was surprised that he
went c4 I'd be five and close the M
close the Queen side I don't know it
filled some fields very slow this kind
of play but maybe a five before my ideas
age six and I'm provoke him or provoke
you into this now I'm said I'm setting
up a sacrifice on h6 what I don't get it
Knight a5 don't you want any kind of
gown to play with a five before hmm ok
so that's an interesting moment i can
actually consider to take on age seven
check and sacrifice on age 6 it's close
to working really is but let's just
prepare things here
damn should I just go back to the one
and grab that be three pawn or continue
to attack yeah public water would
probably say I'll vote among the viewers
public would I think of something from
the US election system would probably
vote for continued to attack but taking
this is also not bad and without the
light squared Bishop it's a bit
difficult to learn to check made so
let's take take this pawn and then
Bishop d3 c3 just to cover everything
ok 5 here or no probably not not going
to go into help
that is a good move maybe going to go to
f5 or reform something like that yeah I
have to have to regroup here anyway just
wonder how 92 or something maybe look
III as a move this is a move maybe yeah
preparing okay one sequin for a 95 or
something like that welcome to her to
the world of tricks f 1 93 takes tape
and then he takes h5 or crazy maybe I
can do it just do this
yeah I'm not sure about it poor takes is
the better structure but I'd like to get
in a quick we need seven here check so
how to flame and we can really can
invade their queen d 7 or something I
yes got f7 protected of course that is
that was stupid time morning he has a
very good protection of this pawn oh man
yeah that field said that's a bad loss
going to be a bad loss problem after I
mean White's position around 20 or so
move 20 was just overwhelmingly good you
really really have to win this position
maybe we can take and play Bishop f3
there now no not even going for this I'm
happy I am NOT checkmated him check
ah sorry about that check he could do
anything about it god it's taking Aegis
them I wonder if this is an engine again
what kind of wood kind of hit yeah I am
I mean I had the suspicion all the way
but now it is painstakingly clear that
it is an engine black forfeit hahahahaha
what a joke he never he never got to
play quicker moves everything with the
others engine o mine I don't know what I
would get what what do people get out of
this I don't understand it really don't
understand it it looked it very engine
like this is rubbish opening yeah people
tend to like to play the computer and
give the computer rubbish openings to
play yeah this this is just this is just
a mistake then then we had to be at 95
this is really a little bit like bad
computer sometimes plane k and here this
is the real question and smoked fish
actually also wants to take the pawn hmm
yeah maybe not not the second pawn
yeah this is probably wrong the very
difficult to analyze stop which actually
wants me to take but it didn't it didn't
give a clear evaluation I just had a
line like that and said slight edge for
white which is not helping a lot maybe
queen F for coming that gives equal very
mysterious yeah maybe I should really
take with the pawn and stop which gives
me an advantage all the way and here it
gives equal I really absolutely only he
understood that absolutely no play again
step 7 which is rather embarrassing
check I always take 66 in a couple of
seconds seven seconds and here you just
even he say head on the clock and has
got an extra porn black can play any any
kind of move and still five seconds and
so on and lost on time how crazy is that
how crazy is that come on let's do
something funny here yeah he had a game
here that he wanted let's check how
computer is then Luton times time spent
i look at the tire oh that took a little
bit longer check check
always a couple of seconds it was so bad
that car was resigned him so but what
about games that he lost lost against
professor Smith how did that work out
and some it's actually better for for
black but hmm I don't know hmm maybe I'm
seeing go see I don't know this place
very slowly but but very steadily slowly
check and i'm mostly looking at the time
you know like black also called our
platoon yeah i don't know maybe yes
something else is going on there just
felt so weird that he didn't ever
increased his speed and in that game
that and it looked a bit computer ish
that whole opening and so on but yeah
very very real stuff okay thanks for
watching